Napa will find this secret file on the
new puppy we'll never get through that
door no not that door the doggy door how
do we get past the guard ah no no no no
no no no way no it she washi lumpy bad
[Music]
yeah all the way down I've never been so
humiliated in all my life
[Music]
[Music]
what about doing whoa
[Music]
Oh
oh no no biting
everything gonna Oh
watch Oh what is it mmm gotta be near
it's almost like it begging us to go in
wow that's a lot of paperwork huh I
thought puppies shredded everything this
is getting creepy
I've come to yourself cut it out wait
huh that's it
file see I wouldn't write ah nope I've
seen this before somewhere
you've got to find something to replace
it with powder right like another file
Wow yes if I would have seen wait Carol
can be placed in the exact same position
ah exact single already said I know I
said it oh hey really Dwight I like it a
third time
wait I think I've seen
about pressboard edges across 50 ounces
no 49 try this one now it's fun
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like we should run I know it's
just so mesmerizing the car would be out
in damage well that didn't end well what
I don't where nautical it's not even
Friday ah what have you done to me Apple
no oh no way hey what's all the racket
oh isn't he adorable
oh I've got one for you too ahoy matey
Oh what come on smile for the camera it
makes me feel weak you think it is a
place it doesn't more come back here I'm
dead down there come on
everyone has people spot oh come one
step closer and I'll illuminate you with
a soft glow and I'll clean your clock Oh
blimey look you've all made an excellent
decision to see this movie you're
clearly shrewd so let me lay this out
for you on March 31st my movie
DreamWorks the boss baby will be coming
out we don't have any talking
candlesticks but if that's a deal
breaker will cram one in there somewhere
[Music]
what does
I think the kid might be onto me oh yeah
but look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice I'm on a mission
puppies are women and babies are losing
my job is to find out why now see if
there's someplace around here with
decent sushi I'd kill for a spicy tuna
roll right about now I will help you
just to get rid of me deal how do we get
back the card we're not gonna play
anything on what's all the racket did he
adorable I've got one for you too what
well I can't do this without the pen but
you make a pretty good clue no literally
I can't reach the door
I never don't look you really didn't
know we like
[Music]
what's that cookie down
cookies stopper closer I think we hate
each other hate is a strong word it's
the right word but still we have to
convince them that we like no no no way
no you don't mean
we babies are having a crisis oh well
it's simpler if I just show Kenny could
you please come on put on a show here we
go
Jimbo hit the Lights you see babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to great behold our mortal enemy
Oh No that's exactly the problem it is
war
puppies are winning and babies are
losing all bad news baby
what are we going to do you're going to
help me alright you still got it boss
yeah yay now your parents will work for
puppy Co so have you learned anything
from them yes sir ding majestic good
let's go a b c d yo what have you
learned about puppies very puppies no
Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey Rebecca
knows I can't read what could say this
you're my team a musclehead a bunch of
yes men and a doodler yeah what that
cookie down cookies stopper closer
oh it's like a having their own little
meeting humiliating
Wow yeah yeah I know what you thinking
like how helpless he is can't even
change his own diaper well
can't or won't diapers are all about
power dynamics I poop they wipe BAM
I'm the boss green work the boss baby
I'm a good manager needs a variety of
approaches to get the best out of this
team sometimes you have to be firm put
that cookie down cookies are for closers
sometimes you have to set clear goals
Stacey we bet the notes I can't read
what you say sometimes you need your
cute things I'm working on bring work
the boss baby ha we have two kinds of
customers here at baby core the first
type has researched every option they've
been preparing for years and they know
exactly what they want
the second type of fathers green work
the boss baby
oh you look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice
you think I'm a fussy eater well it's a
power play you want to get me to eat
you'll have to wait and buy my book here
comes the claim
there goes your mind a guide to mealtime
negotiation to order call one 408 555 Oh
100 that's one 408 five five five zero
one zero zero right now baby operators
are standing by
[Music]
Green work the bar Kb
you know who else wears diapers
astronauts and NASCAR drivers that's who
you obviously didn't go to business
school the numbers just don't add up
stay out of my way well there's gonna be
cutbacks let's just say I'm the boss put
that cookie down cookies are for closers
that's what I'm poopin talking about uh
googoo gaga I don't wear an Oracle it's
not even Friday darn my little baby legs
power nap how do you say
thanks for dropping in kids I think
you've met my big brother Eugene a man
of few words none in fact oh surprise
yes
you walked right into my trap mess this
up and I'll fire you just like
mom-and-pop toodaloo to the airport
we are very disappointed in you exactly
we're mad at you you need a timeout
yes grounded for two three date weeks
you're grounded for three weeks meet
your new baby
[Music]
don't be jealous Tim he's just a baby
he's just a baby
he doesn't have a hidden agenda you know
you were a baby once too he's just a
normal baby boy one day you guys will be
best friends if you can stretch it out
about 30 seconds would be great
sure no problem
come on mommy's little cutie are you
mommy's little cutie maybe the baby
should decide who do you want to stay
with you daddy or mommy
oopsie I got it I know isn't he cute
he's like a little man are you taking
over the house yes you are yes you are
that's how I talk to my son
there's always someone trying to take
what's yours how do I know it almost
happened to me at least this is how I
remember it some days I rescued my
parents other days they rescued me it
was just the three of us the Templeton's
and three is the perfect number one
thing was clear he was the boss he had
everyone wrapped around his chubby
little finger everyone except me
you